In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion, per September 19, on which we commemorate, our Holy Father
Theodore of Tarsus, Archbishop of Canterbury.
Saint Theodore was a Greek born at Tarsus in Selissia, about the year 602.
He studied in Athens, acquiring the name of philosopher, and also embraced the monastic
life there.
When he was in his 60s, he went to Rome for learning's sake.
But Pope Vitalion soon consecrated him to the vacant Archbishop of Canterbury.
In order to assure its continued primacy in the English Church, at a time of bitter division
in Britain, over the principle of adopting Roman customs in preference to Celtic ones.
In the course of his year-long journey to England, Saint Theodore met Saint Agilbert,
the Bishop of Paris, who was able to inform him about the state of the English Church.
And Theodore began his Episcopal ministry in England by a visitation of the local churches.
He nominated bishops to vacant seas, and summoned a synod at Hartford in the year 672,
that decreed the Roman observance of Easter, regulated jurisdictional disputes between bishops,
and reasserted due order in the monasteries and among the people.
A few years later, he convoked a second synod that confirmed the decrease of the laddering
council against the monotheolite heresy.
In the year 678, a conflict arose between Theodore and Wilfred, who was deposed from the
sea of York for some years.
The two saints were reconciled shortly before Theodore's death when he asked for the reestablishment
of the fiery Wilfred.
Theodore's constant concern in all his pastoral activity was to organize the English Church
in communion with the sea of Rome as being the best means of promoting the unity of the land
and the growth of a Christian culture, enlivened by the contribution of Greek learning.
With this in mind, he established a highly regarded school at Canterbury, where Greek as
well as Latin was taught.
The cultural influence of the monasteries was extended by the study of church music and
of the arts and sciences, that the learned archbishop encouraged them to pursue.
Saint Theodore died in peace on the 19th of September, in the year 690, through the prayers
of our Holy Fathers, O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us and save us.